hey all you cool cats and kittens but if
i felt like she stepped over the line
one more time
i would break her face my name is
alexander hamilton
dale dale dale dell
[Applause]
should we send out a search party for
dale i don't know i am never gonna
financially recover from this
believe it or not that was all this year
you guys and since we've been stuck
inside these tv moments have brought us
together
in moments of joy like never before i'm
joined by ash crosston and
lauren zema and we're going to talk
about our top tv moments of 2020
and i know we've each have our own pick
so ash you want to kick things off for
us
yes so my number three pick i'm going
with love is blind so this came out
february 13th so we weren't quite in
quarantine yet
this was the show i felt like shouldn't
have worked
but it worked better than almost any
other like dating reality show we had
lauren and cameron who are now happily
married for two years we have amber and
burnett
also happily married for two years gene
uh giannina and damien still together
and then we have mark and jessica not
together
but gave us some of the best moments of
reality tv of the year possibly of the
decade
wine will go down in his in reality tv
history
100 we got viral moments and what blew
my mind about love is blind is
it was one of those shows that really
benefited from the quarantine right it
hit
right at that time as you said when we
were all at home so
people were totally glued to their tvs i
don't think it would have been as
big of a success without that quarantine
boost when everybody was just streaming
and looking for things to binge
and it was crazy too because then we had
to analyze
and figure out like when was this
actually filmed are these people
together they had been so good about not
posting
anything on their social media it was
almost like a next part of the show to
figure out wait who's with who
and when did this all actually happen
and how did it work
i mean everybody mark and jessica her
complaining about
her age all the time and not really
giving him a chance giannina who was
you know she was a little cuckoo she was
a little cute she belonged on reality
television
exactly and then lauren and cameron
where it's like i don't think these two
would have ever crossed paths anywhere
else except the show
and then they completely fell in love
and it surprised them too i was here for
it
love is blind danny what's your number
three pick okay
mine is the real housewives franchise
that we had multiple franchises this
year right lauren and i am
gonna admit i am late to the housewives
party i just hopped on the train i had
hopped on the bandwagon
quarantine i was like let's see what all
the fuss is about but i did it right
i actually educated myself on past
seasons of beverly hills
and potomac before the new seasons aired
this year and now i
am hooked i mean i don't won't get into
the gritty details but like the plot
points this year included
randy glanville dropping a major
bombshell that she hooked up with denise
richards
richards she claims that tensions
between candice
and monique and potomac fever pitch
which led to this
altercation during wine tasting a
physical opportunity
a physical altercation i mean you are a
huge fan of the housewives franchise
lauren don't you feel they're at their
peak right now
totally and i think well peak okay
here's what i will say i love
that the quarantine
not only gave us some stuff that like
got the spotlight on it if
uh it had if we hadn't all been glued to
our tvs but
it also meant that people got into shows
they hadn't gotten into before just like
you
the quarantined silver lining danny
directo started watching housewives i
can
happen to tell you about it yes um and
so i i think shows got new fans but yeah
housewives
here's the thing we had tons of
crazy moments this year on different
franchises
and we also had to uh see the housewives
endure the pandemic because our reality
shows we're filming when all this was
happening right
so right now we're watching the real
housewives of orange county what they
filmed a couple months ago
like dealing with covid and we're
watching it and so it's just making for
wild reality tv plus
we got a new franchise for the first
time in years the real housewives of
salt lake city
which i am saying here and now gave us
the best premiere
of any tv show in the bravo network's
history
denny you said you started late i just
started my first
real housewives watch i'm starting with
beverly hills because i was a vanderpump
rules fan
i have just finished season three but
that is all the housewives i've ever
watched and i'm
obsessed it's feeling
so grateful right now thank you i know
thank you lord you've been trying to
tell us you've been trying to tell us
but it's pure entertainment and that's
what we need this year and also it's a
little bit of escapism
and on that note lauren what was your
pick
for one of your favorite tv shows this
year i don't know if there could have
been
something more literally escapist my
number three pick
is netflix's emily in paris or should i
say
emily in paris or should i say emilian
pelley
so literally it took us there the show
starred lily collins
as its main character emily an american
who
finds herself working a job in paris and
it gave us a lot of i will say
low-hanging fruit of humor like
oh the american in paris acting like an
idiotic american
and doing some uh not so cultural things
including her fashion in the beginning
but
the reason i got so obsessed with it it
was an easy watch it's from sex and the
city creator darren starr and it was
just
fashionable romantic escapism plus
it had literally been filmed in paris so
at a time when we could not travel
i was taken abroad because you know what
let's be real
is it the most creative show or
well-written show
isn't that good questionable at best but
the fashion uh the fact that it is shot
in paris and you do
get kind of swept away with the kind of
outlandish parts of it you know
in a time like you mentioned uh lauren
where we're just like stuck at home
and dealing with harsh realities it was
kind of nice to go on a trip
trip to paris okay my number two pick
is the return of the mandalorian we
needed baby yoda to save us in 2020 and
boy did he listen this show
was a little bit formulaic in the last
season
but this new season has just opened
the floodgates of star wars into my
soul it's just everything i could have
ever wanted like
i never thought to your veins this show
has consistently proved me wrong on
things that i think about star wars i'm
like i'm like oh i never want a
live-action star wars it'll never be
done that great
this show is fantastic i'm like i never
want to learn baby yoda's name because
it can't be as good as baby yoda
i was mistaken grogu is adorable
i never want to see live action ahsoka
rosario dawson comes in with her
two dual white lightsabers and just
slays it it is a fantastic show
and um the future is just brighter than
ever for star wars television
on that note my number two pick is a
reality competition series that has
existed for a minute now
but still delivered in its prime 12
seasons later and i'm talking about
rupaul's drag race i mean you guys know
i'm a hardcore fan of this show uh but i
feel like this past
year we not only did did we get season
12 of rupaul's drag race we also got
all stars five and it's just the amount
of talent
on this show it's getting harder and
harder to compete because it really is
anybody's game at this point
i mean season 12 i i couldn't predict
the winner it went to jada essence hall
and our all-stars five winner was shay
coulee
uh two black queens who really delivered
on
on all cylinders i mean they were like
personality so creative they could sew
they could lip sync for their lives uh
but what was interesting with season 12
in particular you guys
was to see it finish during the pandemic
because the show is pre-taped up until
the finale so the top three
had to compete for the crown via zoom at
home and so to watch that play out was
so fascinating and like drag race always
has
it's just um it's amazing to watch these
queer people
who are part of these marginalized
communities some of them
in the middle of nowhere really become
drag race superstars where they
whether they won or not and also just to
see all that creativity
and they have to do so much on that show
to win i mean there's no wonder at one
another at me
danny rupaul is to me as housewives was
to you and because you started watching
housewives i'm
i'm gonna it's not because i don't think
i'll like it i'm just like do i have any
more space in my tv brain and i know
there's so much history and lore with
rupaul's drag race that i need to like
catch up but you did it with housewives
i'm gonna dive in
you can dive in the next season you
don't have to go back and watch previous
seasons unless you're watching all stars
but season
13 get right into it just like i got
into
the bachelorette not too long ago lauren
you you really jumped in on all my shows
this year and i appreciate that i do
i know ash is watching guys the
mandalorian is only two seasons if you
guys want to jump in
i do i should watch that too actually i
should watch that too no for real
so you want to talk about a show trying
to figure out how to keep going
in the pandemic i have to say the
bachelorette was on the forefront
their season for the first time in the
franchise is almost
20-year history production was literally
put on halt
as they were about to film night one of
the limo entrances
that was uh that march 13th week where
pretty much everything shut down for all
of us they put things on hold for a
while and then
they were one of the first big shows to
get going again
in the pandemic so they took the whole
cast and crew
again for the first time ever to a
quarantined bubble
at the la quinta resort in palm springs
california
and filmed it there and the reason that
it is my number two pick
is twofold one and by the way both of
these things i think are a result
in part of everything i just said um we
had our girl claire crowley the
bachelorette
she's sitting at home waiting for months
she's got the chance to look up her guys
on the internet
no lead has ever had this opportunity in
this downtime before
and when claire arrives at the laquinta
palm springs
she says something no lead has ever said
before after her night one
limo entrances she says of dale moss and
i quote
i think i just met my husband
game over game over they end up having
one huge moment this is my top two pick
they end up having
the shortest route to an engagement in
show history
which means production then has to bring
in a second lead ms tasha adams making
this
the first time ever we've replaced a
lead midway through a season
so i think the pandemic was in part
the reason all this happened and it just
made for i mean you talk about like
the show's been on for 20 years there
are some seasons that just stick
out and this season is gonna go down in
history i feel like no matter who you
are
where you were whether you watched the
show or not you knew what was going on
with the bachelorette this season
i actually watched it and i never
watched the bachelorette but i was like
this has been so hyped up it seems so
interesting what is going on with this
woman because i watch
of course i watch roses and rose that's
usually how i get on my bachelor info
um but i watched it because i was like
how many times is she gonna say dale
and i played a little drinking game and
um i i died now i'm a ghost
now you're a ghost now you're a ghost we
have like we need to do a montage of her
dale dale dale dill dale like just put
it in here
dale plus kleiner dale plus claire dale
dale dale dell
i feel like because of the the um
shutdown production shutting down
because of the pandemic
i felt like it took longer to get to the
show
than it did for her to fall in love with
one of the contestants but i will say
when you take that away the pandemic the
fact that
claire was replaced by tasia as i
continue to watch the show
i realized that this is also a crop and
a batch of guys i i feel like i've never
seen on this franchise and i think a lot
of it has to do with the fact that we're
living in such a vulnerable time
and they had to jump through so many
hoops to get to the show
only for claire to peace out with dale
and now they're
in it i mean this was a test of their
commitment and now they are really
fighting and vying for
teachers heart by opening up theirs uh
like there's been some emotional
episodes and i feel like the guys are
the driving force of this season too
okay i really don't have much to add to
this beyond the fact that it was just
like a cultural reset of the year but in
july
they dropped hamilton on disney plus
and the world turned upside down
i mean i was non-stop
playing that soundtrack and i still am
and guys i need to embarrass myself
really quick because
the spotify wrapped playlists came out
where they tell you like
what you listen to all year and i was in
the top four percent of people that
listened to the hamilton soundtrack
and then they showed me my top artists
and it was
not a single non-hamilton moment on my
top artist that is
humiliating but i'm also simultaneously
very proud of it
can we blame you and you're talking to
two theater nerds right here lauren and
i
i i support this 100 especially
when again because the pandemic all
theater production shut down
hamilton was actually here in l.a right
when the shutdown happened so
i think a handful of people probably got
to see it but now the whole world got to
see because of disney plus
i was that was appointment viewing for
me you know hamilton for years was that
coveted theater ticket like you could
not get it in new york and then it was
maybe in a couple other big cities
and i think for the most of the country
you were
hearing about it but you weren't
actually able to see it so streaming
and again kind of like the reset that
we've had of
wait what can we achieve online through
streaming through zoom because
of being quarantined i think hopefully
it brings more
theater to more people and i know i
didn't listen to the soundtrack
for years because i was like i want to
see the show first and i want to see it
in context i just don't want to listen
to the music first
so i never even listen to the soundtrack
and i hope yeah i hope they do this with
more stuff put mama mia on disney plus
please
let's not forget that this was also a
treat for people who did get a chance to
see hamilton live because let's not
let's be real it's a hot ticket that
else was very expensive so you know for
those people in the nosebleeds they
finally got to see it up close so
like jonathan broth
i saw it at the pantages in la a couple
years ago
and i i felt like i needed to re-watch
it just because they go so fast
i'm like yeah i only got one shot to
understand the lyrics and i didn't get
them all i need to
so it took me like five times to
understand what happened in hamilton
and now i'm like one of those people
like i watched it with my mom and i was
like
so now he's talking about rebuilding the
financial like the treasury and my mom's
like shut up please stop
stop we got entertainment and a history
lesson i'm your friend
well from tony winners to emmy winners
because my number one
favorite tv series of the year is shit's
creek
i mean what is not to love about this
show
the first thing that comes to mind for
me actually is that i watched it early
on when it first premiered because i'm a
huge catherine o'hara fan
uh and eugene levy too like i love all
those christopher guest movies
but the journey this show has had from
this canadian show on
pop tv for us here in america to this
like
emmy juggernaut juggernaut it's insane
and also
not to mention the fact that you know
obviously we've seen
uh a lot more diversity on tv this year
certainly a lot more lgbtq
plus visibility but this show is a
it lives in this perfect bubble where
it's you know queer
but also has had this considerable
mainstream success
and everyone loves it you know and i
think we have netflix to thank for that
but
it came to a perfect close this year and
subsequently
swept the cat the comedy categories in
the emmys and i think
it is so well deserving i know you guys
love the show too you want to talk about
a show that got a life because of the
quarantine and from being available on
streaming
i had heard about shit's creek like
being in the industry i think people in
media have always loved shit's creek but
all of a sudden
friends of mine from college and
neighbors were like are you watching
shit's creek
and it really made me happy to see that
this show
uh could have mainstream appeal like
this not just mainstream appeal but
critical appeal and
and just be something sort of beloved
across the board because
at the center of it it is like a story
about a family still and i think we all
got that perspective this year too
and it's actually funny yes it's so
funny
and i think it was i think last the
previous year at the emmys i think it
only got like
one nomination so then to see it like
get its due and completely sweep in its
final season
was so beautiful and i think it was like
season four or something that mariah
carey
tweeted about shit's creek and was like
i love this show
and i think that's like when it started
to
blow up okay lauren what was your number
one pick
for your favorite tv show of 2020
i think the only way to introduce it is
to say
carol baskin guilder
i don't remember the tick tock dance um
allegedly allegedly i'm just quoting the
tick-tock dance
um tiger king you guys we've been
talking about shows benefiting from the
quarantine hitting right at the right
time
this show is not my number one pick
because it undoubtedly
was the show of quarantining and staying
at home
tiger king the uh docu-series
dropped on netflix right when we all
were staying inside our houses with our
families wanting something to watch
and it absolutely blew up in terms of
numbers of streams
the story of joe exotic and his animal
park and his archrival carol baskin
and how he wound up in jail for
allegedly being part of a plot to kill
her
it was wild it became memes it became
tick-tock dances it became
merchandise and t-shirts and halloween
kim kardashian dressed up
as carol baskin and made her kids tigers
carol baskin wound up on dancing with
the stars where she addressed
a lot of the controversy so i don't know
if there was something
that more so embodies like the cultural
moment we're having years from now
we will all remember tiger king no i
think you're so right i think this is
like
love it or hate it because i think like
we've all gone through a personal
journey with tiger king where we were
really into it and then i was really
not into it like and i was like why are
you still talking about tiger king
but it was just like this moment we all
watched it at the same time i've never
seen
anything like that that show actually
really did
actually hit netflix right when the stan
home orders were being put in place
you know and uh what else were we doing
right except like we needed some stuff
to watch
but just to see the cultural impact like
you uh explained lauren
and like the fact that carol baskin
besides being on dancing with the stars
was also like name checked in a megan d
stallion
song body yada yada yada like that tells
you how
how much this show really i don't know
influenced a bunch of people
and not to mention the fact that we're
forgetting that it really did introduce
us into
this character of carol baskin and
reopened that case about the mysterious
disappearance of her
husband which feels like needs to be
like the tiger king docu-series sequel
i don't know but i think you're right i
think this will this show will
definitely be reflective of this insane
and mad
2020. totally her family like took out
that ad
during her dancing with the st oh my god
the mess
i thought we were never gonna see carol
baskin again after that show because i
she was like devastated and then i think
she like took some time to grieve and
then was like you know what i'm going to
have my moment i'm going to go on
dancing with the star
yes i interviewed her about it i said
carol how did you choose dancing with
the stars because i did et's dancing
with the stars interviews this this year
and she said you know i got probably 150
media requests
um in like the week following tiger king
and you know the biggest outlets we try
to get an interview with her then
she only accidentally did jimmy fallon
she thought i think she got kind of
pranked into
thinking she was doing jimmy fallon and
she wasn't and then
she decided to do dancing with the stars
only because she said her daughter
is such a fan of the show and her
daughter was like mom if you're gonna do
one thing please do dancing with the
stars
i think part of the reason we were also
all so captivated by tiger king was
because
it was such a discussion type of show
you know there
was no clear hero or villain as you
watched each episode you wondered wait
who's done
more wrong here and who is really in the
right here
and we were all still talking about it
and wondering
what really happened to carol baskin's
husband we still are now we don't know
what the future holds i hope we solve it
one day
and just like joe exotic that series had
so many layers to it and every time you
peel something back it just got
wilder and wilder and wilder um
but let me ask you guys do you think
that without quarantining
would tiger king have been a hit ash
i think a very short-lived weekend long
hit
i don't think it would have been
everyone trying to get interviews
uh like a month of talking about it i
don't think any of like the cultural
impact of it would have happened
i'm gonna say yes i think it would have
because of pure
word of mouth like it really was a
really fascinating and wild donkey
series that i said
like i said played just the way it
unfolded and all the different things
that were being thrown into the mix
i feel like people would have definitely
hopped on the bandwagon because
um as we've seen and learned we couldn't
shut up about it
what do you think it also hit right at
that time of
i don't know i agree with you ash i
don't think it would have been as big i
think it would have been like
maybe a slower burn word of mouth but it
also was like
tick-tock got big right at that time and
then we had the tick-tock
it was this perfect storm just like the
story of tiger king itself is this crazy
perfect storm
that creates a story unlike anything
you've heard or could possibly even
believe
and isn't that 20 20.